kommt mit north street 2 bald noch mehr
erdgas von russland nach deutschland
die pipeline soll ein beitrag zur
energiesicherung und zum klimaschutz
sein doch umweltaktivistinnen laufen
sturm trotzdem zwei ist erst mal hoch
klimaschädlich also wir haben 100
millionen tonnen co2 im jahr ausgestoßen
werden die neue pipeline nord stream 2
wird über eine länge von 1230 kilometern
von russland aus bis nach lubmin in
mecklenburg vorpommern reichen sie kann
im jahr 55 milliarden kubikmeter gas
transportieren mehr als die hälfte des
jährlichen deutschen erdgasverbrauchs
mit nord stream zwei könnten die gas
leitungen durch die ukraine und durch
polen umgangen werden so wird russland
in seiner position gestärkt und kann
druck auf osteuropa ausüben herr der
pipeline ist alexej miller ein
vertrauter des russischen staatschefs er
leitet den russischen staatskonzern
gazprom den haupteigner von nord stream
2 gazprom ist das größte
erdgasförderunternehmen der welt
zusammen mit fünf europäischen
energieunternehmen investiert gazprom
rund zehn milliarden euro in das projekt
befürworter sehen in der pipeline eine
moderne brückentechnologie auf dem weg
zu erneuerbaren energien
auch für die nord stream zwei ag ist die
pipeline ein beitrag zum klimaschutz
noch an bord des verleger schiffs werden
die rohre zusammengeschweißt alles muss
hundertprozentig dicht sein damit kein
gas entweicht über eine riesige rampe
werden die rohre dann bis zu 200 meter
tief ins meer geleitet die pipeline
baustelle ein geschenk für die
strukturschwache region im nordosten
deutschlands
entsprechend besorgt war die
landesregierung von mecklenburg
vorpommern als die us regierung unter
präsident trump damit begann den bau der
pipeline mit sanktionen zu gefährden
eine stiftung wurde gegründet die klima-
und umweltschutz mv genau das wird in
der satzung auch als hauptzweck genannt
weiter nennt die satzung der
gemeinnützigen stiftung als zweck die
sicherung des baus von nord stream 2 das
gründungskapital der stiftung stammt nur
zu einem prozent von der regierung in
schwerin
200.000 euro das hundertfache nämlich 20
millionen euro gibt die nordstream zwei
ag dazu
umweltverbände sie in der stiftung
enttäuschung manöver denn eine
erdgaspipeline dienen nicht dem schutz
des klimas sondern bewirkt eher das
gegenteil
dass mecklenburg vorpommern und russland
gemeinsame interessen verfolgen
demonstriert die landesregierung mit
ihrem russland tag das bundesweit größte
deutsch-russische wirtschaftstreffen
findet alle drei jahre statt in diesem
jahr in angespannter politischer lage zu
russland nach der verhaftung von alexei
navalny und trotz corona pandemie das
hat kritik ausgelöst
[Musik]
blumen für den russischen botschafter
image pflege für die guten deutsch
russischen beziehungen
nord stream 2 gehört zu den
großzügigsten sponsoren der
veranstaltung
eine frage für jeden pressevertreter die
abschlusspressekonferenz frau schrie
sich sie haben gesagt deutschland
braucht die pipeline die hat aber nach
wie vor viele kritiker wie ernst nehmen
sie deren argumente
selbstverständlich haben wir uns mit
diesen argumenten auseinander gesetzt
und auch gespräche geführt und
wir kommen zu einer anderen entscheidung
für eine gelingende energiewende die
gleichzeitig dafür sorgt dass die
industrienationen deutschland
wirtschaftlich stabil bleibt brauchen
wir gas noch zeitlich befristet für eine
übergangszeit und wir in mecklenburg
vorpommern setzen auf das gas aus der
pipeline
journalisten fragen zum umgang russlands
mit der opposition beantwortet manuela
schwesig ausreichend und natürlich
gehört auch zum dialog eine kritische
auseinandersetzung über dinge die wir
eben unterschiedlich sehen zum beispiel
der umgang mit oppositionellen aber
sprachlosigkeit kann nicht die richtige
antwort in diesen schwierigen zeiten
seien sondern es muss der dialog seien
dialog das klingt vernünftig aber
braucht deutschland wirklich die
russische pipeline nord stream 2 in
brüssel sieht man die deutsche haltung
mit sorge seit jahren stimmt eine
deutliche mehrheit der
europaparlamentarier immer wieder für
einen stopp von nord stream 2 auch nach
der verhaftung von alexei navalny
sergey lagodinsky ist mitglied des
auswärtigen ausschusses des
europaparlaments die pipeline wird ja
nun wohl fertig gestellt obwohl viele
kreise in europa dagegen sind auch
dagegen gestimmt haben warum eigentlich
dieses projekt ist eine katastrophe für
die deutsche glaubwürdigkeit als
europäischer
als akteur und das ist etwas was wir
hier auch im parlament immer wieder
sehen dass wir in deutschland und das
ist etwas was mir auch persönlich sehr
weh tut dass wir als deutscher immer
angesehen werden als diejenigen die bei
der europa- solidarität am schwächsten
da stehen deutschland macht so viel für
europäische zukunft und dieses projekt
bringt das alles in verruf das geht so
nicht doch die bundesregierung hält an
nordstream 2 fest aber sie will dafür
sorgen dass auch in zukunft gas durch
die ukraine fließt sollte russland die
ukraine bedrohen und energie als waffe
einsetzen würde deutschland
gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen so die
vereinbarung mit den usa dann haben wir
natürlich auch die möglichkeit von derek
nicht gebrauch machen möchte aber die
lehrer immer haben sanktionen zu machen
also wir sind ja nicht ohne jedes mittel
etwas zu tun reicht das um die kritiker
in osteuropa zu beruhigen ich habe einen
termin in der polnischen botschaft in
berlin sofort nach der
deutsch-amerikanischen einigung hatten
polen und die ukraine gemeinsam gegen
die vereinbarungen protestiert wir haben
lange gegen nachdem zwei gekämpft durch
die durch den wechsel in den vereinigten
staaten durch in ein präsident ist eine
entscheidung gefallen die uns nicht
gefällt aber wir müssen sie akzeptieren
also putin hält sich nach an seine
versprechungen nicht kann sogar sagen
wir diese ukrainische pipeline zerstören
durch
rebellen die irin ukraine hat und dann
sagen lieferungen durch die ukraine sind
technisch nicht möglich und wer wäre
wird das überprüfen ja also wir glauben
putin nicht und ich sehe nicht an der
seite der deutschen regierung die mitte
dieser versprechungen zu erzwingen was
sagt die bundesregierung dazu das
auswärtige amt will uns zu diesem thema
kein interview geben wie in deutschland
der ausbau von gas infrastruktur
vorangetrieben wird zeigt sich hier in
brandenburg
die anschlussleitung von nord stream 2
führt vom mecklenburgischen lubmin aus
über 480 kilometer in zwei strängen bis
nach tschechien etwa drei milliarden
euro wurden für den bau veranschlagt
sobald nord stream 2 ans netz geht
können hier ebenfalls 55 milliarden
kubikmeter gas jährlich durch fließen
sowohl landbesitzer als auch
umweltschützer hatten so sagen sie kaum
eine chance den bau zu verhindern
ich bin verabredet mit dem journalisten
malte heinen er ist besitzer eines
ackers stücks das direkt auf der trasse
der pipeline egal liegt nach angaben der
ausführenden firma kaskade mussten etwa
6000 verträge mit landbesitzern entlang
der strecke geschlossen werden bevor die
pipeline verlegt werden konnte feinen
lehnte die angebotene entschädigung ab
er wurde enteignet und klagte gegen die
genehmigungsbehörde
als ich das schreiben bekommen habe dass
sie hier noch eine neue gasleitung
verlegen wollen
da wusste ich erst mal gar nichts damit
anzufangen dann habe ich herausgefunden
da steckt auch gasproben dahinter da
habe ich angefangen zu recherchieren und
das erste was ich herausgefunden habe
ist das gas überhaupt nicht weniger
klimaschädlich ist als kohle oder öl das
hört man ja oft nur das sei so eine
brückentechnologie das dachte ich auch
und dann habe ich beschlossen dass ich
was gegen das projekt unternehmen möchte
und das erfolgreich offensichtlich nicht
also das gerichtsverfahren ist noch
offen wir sind jetzt in der letzten
instanz vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
grundsätzlich muss die zuständige
behörde prüfen ob eine neue gasleitung
überhaupt notwendig ist dabei kommt es
besonders auf eine zahl an wie groß wird
der gasverbrauch in zukunft sein bei
dieser zahl haben die sich nur auf
studien gestützt sie von der
gasindustrie selber kommen es wird die
gasindustrie sagt welche annahmen
treffen sie für die studien welche
methoden wehren die behörde hat
keinerlei unabhängige studien zu rate
gezogen und als ich das haus gefunden
habe habe ich das kann doch nicht wahr
sein das heißt also die gasindustrie
rechtfertigt sich selber also es schafft
sich selber die gesetzliche grundlage
genau dafür dass das hier verlegt genau
die gasindustrie schreibt sich selber
die studien die dann bescheinigen dass
diese gasleitung gebraucht wird und auf
grundlage dieser studien wird dann die
gasleitung genehmigt also im grunde
haben sie sich das selber genehmigt weil
die behörde ja keine anderen studien
angeschaut hat auf nachfrage teilt uns
das bergamt cottbus als zuständige
behörde mit dass die genehmigung für
egal tatsächlich auf prognosen der
netzbetreiber beruhte außerdem auch auf
stellungnahmen der bundesnetzagentur
meine recherchen scheint zu bestätigen
was malte reinen sagt das sind die
verbände der netzbetreiber selbst die
alle zwei jahre neue netz
entwicklungspläne erstellen zb für die
jahre 2020 bis 2030 von fünf
vorgestellten prognosen wurden nur zwei
szenarien berücksichtigt die einen
steigenden oder moderat sinkenden
gasbedarf vorhergesagt haben die anderen
blieben unberücksichtigt
laut europäischen rechnungshof hat auch
die eu kommission in der vergangenheit
den gasbedarf regelmäßig viel zu hoch
eingeschätzt denn auch sie hat sich
früher auf die angaben der netzbetreiber
gestützt
in berlin treffe ich claudia kemfert vom
deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung sie ist dort
leiterin der abteilung energie und
umwelt und gehört dem umweltrat der
bundesregierung an braucht deutschland
braucht europa nord zum 2
deutschland europa brauchen beide nicht
in austin zwei wir haben ausreichend
infrastruktur kapazitäten in europa wir
werden in der zukunft einen abnehmenden
fossilen erdgasbedarf haben und aus dem
grund brauchen wir keine zusätzliche
neue pipeline und damit diese pipeline
sich rechnet musste über jahrzehnte
ausgelastet sein das ist nicht
kompatibel mit den energiewende ziehen
auch nicht mit den klimazielen und aus
dem grund kann es gar keine brücke sein
sondern sie behindert er den umstieg hin
zu einer vollversorgung aus erneuerbaren
energien ist praktisch eine brücke ins
nichts nord stream zwei sei also nicht
notwendig für die energiewende aber
schadet das milliarden-projekt dem klima
wie umweltorganisationen behaupten in
der mecklenburgischen landeshauptstadt
schwerin treffe ich aktivistinnen von
friday the future bei einer demo sie
protestieren gegen die pipeline nord
stream 2 und gegen die klimapolitik der
landesregierung
[Musik]
theresia krone hatte zunächst an einem
jugendbeirat der landesregierung
mitgearbeitet trat aber aus protest
gegen die umstrittene umweltstiftung
zurück
weil ich das gefühl hatte ich muss jetzt
an dieser stelle
glaubwürdigkeit waren integrität
bewahren haltung zeigen
jugend partizipation ist super wichtig
aber ich glaube auch als jugendliche
muss man nicht entscheidungen mittragen
die komplett gegen die eigenen werte
gehen
fossile energieträger wie erdgas haben
für theresia krone und ihre
mitstreiterinnen keine zukunft mehr
[Musik]
platz zwei ist erst mal hoch
klimaschädlich also wir haben 100
millionen tonnen co2 die im jahr
ausgestoßen werden zusätzlich kommt noch
der methanausstoß durch die gas gas
transporte und dieses fossile
megaprojekt ist einfach ein riesen
schritt in die falsche richtung und
verstößt auch gegen das pariser
klimaabkommen gegen das 1,5 grad ziel
und das können uns aktuell nicht mehr
leisten ist erdgas wirklich so
klimaschädlich wie theresia krone
behauptet
bei der verbrennung von gas wird wie bei
allen fossilen brennstoffen co2
freigesetzt
dazu kommt methan das bei der
gasproduktion und bei den gastransport
anfällt dieses gas wirkt laut aktuellem
klimabericht bis zu 87 mal mehr
klimaerwärmung als co2
auf dem höchsten berg deutschlands ist
die luft meistens besonders rein ich
habe von einem labor des karlsruher
instituts für technologie in 3000 metern
höhe gehört
hier wird die zusammensetzung der
atmosphäre gescannt schon lange
beobachtet klimaforscher ralf sassmann
einen signifikanten anstieg des methans
ralf husmann hat einen weg gefunden
herauszufinden woher dieses gas kommt es
gibt bei den menschgemachten
methanquellen zwei wesentliche klassen
das ist einmal das biogene mit annas
folgendes prozessen dann gibt es das
fossile methan aus leckagen bei der öl
und gasförderung wir haben uns jetzt den
beitrag aus der öl und gasförderung
angeschaut das gelingt mit infrarot
spektrometer wie wir hier auf der
zugspitze haben wenn man damit nicht nur
das methan misst sondern zeitgleich eben
auch das itan in der atmosphäre wenn man
es so dass bei den öl- und gasquellen
immer auch ertan mit anfällt bei den
jungen quellen landwirtschaft
abfallwirtschaft fällt das eltern
überhaupt nicht mit an somit kann man
die quellen unterscheiden unsere
messungen zeigen nun seit 2007 steigt
auch das ethanol rapide plötzlich an
parallel zum methan und damit können wir
jetzt ausrechnen mindestens 40 prozent
des gesamten methan anstiegs seit 2007
ist auf die öl und gasförderung
zurückzuführen nicht nur folgendes
prozesse wie man immer dachte sondern
leckagen bei dem erdgas transport und
der produktion sind also
mitverantwortlich für den anstieg des
methans in der atmosphäre
wir wissen also unbedingt diesen anstieg
eindämmen hin zu steigenden emissionen
nur so kann man weitere klimaerwärmung
dass durch das methan verhindern das
heißt also die tatsache dass methan
nicht so lange atmosphäre bleibt
bedeutet nicht dass methan weniger
schädlich ist ganz im gegenteil im
ersten jahrzehnten ist es deutlich side
legal als man bisher angenommen hat
wieviel leckagen es gibt und wie viel
methan aus den einzelnen pipelines
entweicht das weiß auch ralf husmann
nicht
doch in dem ort manno in brandenburg
wird deutlich was der wissenschaftler
meint entlang von pipelines finden sich
immer wieder anlagen die das erdgas
komprimieren um druck verluste
auszugleichen
in manno befindet sich eine solche
vernichtungsanlage methan ist geruch und
farblos und daher schwer aufzuspüren
doch die aufnahmen einer spezialkamera
mit der auch die gasfirmen selbst
leckagen aufspüren zeigen was das auge
normalerweise nicht sieht das
umweltschädliche gas ist als ausdünstung
deutlich zu erkennen
auch deswegen klagt die deutsche
umwelthilfe seit jahren gegen das
pipeline projekt nord stream 2 immer
wieder versuchte sie den bau mit
rechtlichen mitteln zu verhindern bisher
jedoch ohne großen erfolg
aber noch sind verfahren offen der
leiter für den bereich energie und klima
constantin zager befürchtet dass der
klimaschutz wirtschaftlichen interessen
geopfert wird
nord stream 2 ist das größte fossile
projekt europas steht für mehr als 100
millionen tonnen co2 im jahr und wenn
diese pipeline fertig gebaut wird und in
betrieb geht dann versorgt uns das alle
klimaziele wie laufen diese klagen ab
welche erfahrungen machen sie mit
behörden und gerichten
unsere erfahrung die wir jetzt in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten gesammelt
haben ist dass die behörden sehr
willfährig handeln es wird der weg für
nord stream zwei frei geräumt wo immer
das möglich ist wo immer
ermessenspielraum da ist wird er zu
gunsten der pipeline und zugunsten
dieses fossilen projektes genutzt und
wir kämpfen da eigentlich die ganze zeit
ich würde nicht sagen gegen windmühlen
weil wir haben auch gerichte durchaus
auf unserer seite und auch etappensiege
dort erzielen können aber es ist eben
schon sehr sehr schwieriges verfahren wo
wir immer wieder merken dass behörden da
einfach den zwei sehr sehr wohlgesonnen
sind und wie es deshalb einfach
schwierig haben
das zuständige bundesamt für
seeschifffahrt bestreitet uns gegenüber
die vorwürfe und teilt uns mit dass es
im fall der genehmigung der
rohrleitungen von nord stream zwei
keinen grund gegeben habe diese zu
versagen wir wollen vertreter der
bundesregierung zur pipeline nord stream
zwei befragen nach absagen des außen und
des wirtschaftsministeriums ist man im
bundesumweltministerium zu einem
interview bereit
sie sind der teil der bundesregierung
warum unterstützt die bundesregierung
nord stream 2 die bundesregierung
unterstützt der nicht nur zwei sondern
dass es eine investitionsentscheidung
die getroffen worden ist von privaten
dafür sind genehmigung beantragt worden
und die müssen nach recht und gesetz
beurteilt werden diese genehmigungen
sind erteilt worden und das ist es aber
es gibt doch vorgaben auch von der
bundesregierung um genehmigungsverfahren
und sowas und da werden gas pipelines
wie not sind zum beispiel doch sehr
stark gefördert die nord süd 2 hat eine
genehmigung und diese genehmigung ist
nun vollziehbar die alternative für den
deutschen staat wäre den bau nun zu
verhindern dass würde unmittelbar sehr
hohe schadensersatzforderungen auslöser
und das macht überhaupt keinen sinn denn
die menge an gas die eingesetzt wird
wird nicht durch parkplatz bestimmt
sondern das was in deutschland noch
verstromt oder für die raumwärme
eingesetzt werden darf und das richtet
sich nach dem neuen ehrgeizigen
klimazielen der bundesregierung
wir werden auf dauer auch kein erdgas
mehr einsetzen können deutschland wird
jahr 2045 klimaneutral sein
2040 schon müssen die emissionen um 80
prozent gesenkt sein das bedeutet anfang
der 40er jahre wird in deutschland auch
kein erdgas mehr für strom
eine pipeline durch die vermutlich schon
in 20 jahren kein erdgas mehr fließen
wird eine pipeline deren notwendigkeit
mehr als nur umstritten ist
milliarden-investitionen und politische
unterstützung für ein projekt das den
import von klimaschädlichem erdgas in
riesigen mengen ermöglicht stadt den
ausbau erneuerbarer energien
voranzutreiben
politisch wurde porzellan zerschlagen
und vertrauen verspielt die pipeline
spielt russlands macht streben in die
hände und schürt ängste in osteuropa das
ist der wahre preis der pipeline
[Musik]